ですから後で社会人になっても
またあれ あのラーメン食べたいかなって言ってラーメン食べたりする
だからそういう風に この人の働きっていうものは
同じことをしたってもちょっと差が見えてくる
そこでアビダルマはまあ心理学的なものだから
で 何かものを見ると こっちありますけど
このジンもシーもそれなりに働いています
だから結局言葉で説明はなかなかしにくいんだけど
確実にある働き 一つ人はヴィパッサーナはすごい基本的で
で ヴィチャーラはもっとスモールして
すごい微妙で細かいということ
それものすごい大げさに荒っぽく言えば
考えること 合理的にいろいろめちゃくちゃ考えることなんですね
例えばそれわかるでしょ
例えばこの人 人 人の働きは普通
まあこうだからこうではないか
こうでもまあいろいろ言うでしょ
魚はもうレンジで解凍してはいけませんよとかね
それはまあいろんな話があったりするし
野菜は冷蔵庫に置いた方が
置いといてはいけませんとか
これはこういうこういうわけで悪くなりますよとかね
そういう風にめちゃくちゃ考えちゃう時は
人と視が見えるんです
その働きなんです それは瞬間でもあるということなんです
はい  その 2つはまあ全然わからないと思いますけど
まあ次にいきます それそれで理解すれば
できれば当たり前ですけど
3番目 もっとややこしいんです
この 言葉も日本語では生
生解と書いてます それは読まない方がいいんです
生解だったら全く違うだろうと思いますけど
アディモッカ で あのパーリ語のこのアディモッカということは
この逆に意味を取っているんです
翻訳する人々はそのまま翻訳して生解と優れている
まあ解っていうのは  で
モッカということは このモクシャといってニルバーナ
涅槃という言葉に使ってますよ
解脱に その解脱の解使ってるんですね
でもそれ違うんです モッカっていうのは
このリリース もう逃げていくという意味なんです
出ていくと アディはそれ反対の言葉に逃げていかないように
ですから生解ではないんです
決して でも辞書ではアディっていうのはスーパーという意味で生という意味なんです
辞書を引いてみると アディっていうのは普通ノーマルよりはすごくレベル高いということで
ですから辞書を引けば生は正しい言葉で
モッカは自由にリリース自由になることだから解でいいんです
辞書の意味で アビダルマで考えたのはそんな意味ではないんです
モッカはもうもうルーズ自由になるという意味で
アディっていうのはもうそうならざる
そうしないように付けておくっていうことで
いわゆる解の反対の意味なんです
[笑い]結びというふうな意味なんです
結んでおくと アディモッカっていうのは
そのその瞬間 その瞬間
このやっていることに集中することなんですよ
結局は まあちょっとしたこの心になんか離れないような状態を感じてるんじゃないですか
5時になってくる なってくると
みんなうちに帰る これから料理しなくちゃいけない
ああだこうだとかね あるでしょ？何やっても心からあの対象が逃げないんですね
どこかでもうるうるうるうる
その考え方が それはアディモッカの働きなんです
忘れようとも忘れられないという状態
あるでしょ？いろんなこと
忘れたいんだけど なかなか忘れない
もうもうまたくっついてくる
そういう感じ で そこはそれにあるんだ
いつでも それは過去の今言ったのは過去のことなんですね
過去のことではなくて
えーと まあ大げさなこの体験から見れば
一応わかりやすいことで
まあ例えば自分にも子供が
小さい子供がいるならば
もう学校から帰るだろうという時間になっちゃうと
何やってたっても もうもう外いるならば
その心からもう離れないし
小さな子供連れて行って
このスーパーに買い物に行ったっても
買い物を調べなくちゃいけないし
いろんなものをやらなくちゃいけない
どちらが値段が安いか
今日は掘り出し物なんですか？とも
それ考えなくちゃいけないんだけど
自分の子供のことはやっぱり心から離れないんですね
どこに走ってるんですか？何やってるんですかと
それはいつでももう心のどこかで
裏で もうもうずっと回転している
それはアディモッカの働きなんです
いわゆるこの釘打ったような感じなんです
対象に 釘を打たれてるんだから
もうもう外れないんで
対象から 一般の社会では
世界では本当にもしかすると本当に集中力っていうのはアディモッカかもしれません
この前の七つ目に出てきたのはサマーディ
使う働きで 誰もサマーディのことを考えていないと思います
アディムッカっていうのは
まあちょっとこれはもう心からちょっと離れない
例えば面白い本を買ったと
だから読み終わるまでいろんなことがあって
こうちょっと読んで置いておいて
また でもやっぱりもう終わるまで読みたいということあるでしょうに
そうするともう他のことをやって
すぐまたそこに戻る またまたすぐそこに戻ると
子供はコンピューターゲームがあって
勉強もしなくちゃいけない
で 勉強する間いつでもアディムッカがあっちに引っ張られちゃうし
早くこれを早くあれやりたいとかね
ですからアディムッカの方
アディムッカの方に行ってしまっちゃうというか
正気じゃないんですね
とにかく  パーティモッカもモッカもスモーカも同じ
同じだと思いますね この定義は全然学問の世界で出てこないんです
この今私が言ってる定義が
誰一人使ってない パーティモッカの解釈もなんかすごいおかしいんです
でも僕はこれの意味だとモッカはもう自由になること
パーティっていうのは守って自由になること
なってはならぬと 戒律のことをパーティモッカで言うでしょ？比丘たちの
だから出家しちゃったら
いろんな戒律にも束縛されてるんですよ
好き勝手には行動できないんですね
ですから 好き勝手に行動することできないように守られているとか
戒律で という意味でパーティモッカと言うんです
パーティモッカ日本語訳何でしたっけ？ いや
変な漢字で訳された変な言葉
まあパラダイムモクシャって
それはもう音だけですけどね
やっぱり戒律が聖なる法と防御とか
まあそういう意味でとにかく使ってます
そこでこちらで先週と説明するのは
我々は瞬間瞬間見たり聞いたりする時も
そこから離れないんだから
それ見ている 講義を聞かないで
もし時効の音を聞いたならば
その音から離れないんだから
そこに行ってしまっちゃう
本当は聞きたくないんだけど
もうそこに釘打たれてるんだから
しょうがなくそれ聞いてると
ですから 瞬間瞬間もこのアディムッカが働いている
はい それで説明 その説明を終わります
なんか心にある 何ですか？なんかこの糊みたいなボンドみたいなもんなんですね
その瞬間 その瞬間 それにもうそのその対象につけちゃう
だから一つにずっとついてしまっちゃったら
それをずっとやってしまっちゃう
例えば病気になっちゃったら
もう病気という対象にもうずっと心が居ついてしまって
ずっと他のことを考える暇もなく
何もなく病気のことだけ考えちゃう
うちの中で何かトラブルがあっちゃったら
もう食べる食べられないし
もう何もしない あれそればっかり考えてるでしょうに
ですから もう悩みとかなんとかとか
ずっとなぜ続けるかって
そういうことで そこにもう心がもう釘打たれてるんですね
ですから 続けて考えるだけ
例えば人が悩んでいる人がいて
他のことをやっちゃうと
あの悩みは忘れちゃうでしょうに
悩みだけずっと他のことをやればそれだけのことなんですよ
でも他のことをやっても
このこのこと気になるということは
そこにまだまだアディムッカが働いているということなんですね
ですから それはすごい迷惑で
例えば勉強なんかにアディムッカが働いちゃったら
それは別に迷惑じゃなくて
大変ありがたいことで
自分の仕事にちゃんとアディムッカが働いてくると
それはすごくありがたいことで
ヴィパッサナー瞑想についてでもアディムッカでぐらい働いてくれるならば
もうちゃんと続けて続けていって
何か結果が出てくるんですけどね
瞑想する時でもアディムッカが他のところにあると
なかなかうまくいかない
えーと 次にヴィリヤ ヴィリヤは精進
で これもこのある先週で
あの心でわざとちょっとしたエネルギーを作る
見ようと聞こうと 見ようではないか
聞こうではないか 味わおうではないか
体で感じてみようではないか
考えてみようではないかと
この厳密精神でこの何かしようという
働きが出てくる 努力なんですね
これまたもうここでダブっちゃいますけどね
いわゆる普通だったら
その認識しないかもしれません
例えばあの外のお祭りやるんだと
そうすると自然的に耳がそこに行くのは自然的で
でお祭りあってもそれを無視してこの話聞こうと
その時は精進なんですね
自然的だったら外のお祭りの音を聞くのは自然的であって
そこで精進して いえ こちらを聞くと
こちらの音を聞くと と持ってくる
そのエネルギー いわゆる対象を決める
決めるエネルギーではなくて
決めるために必要なエネルギー
そこも育てられます そこを仏教で厳密に確実に育てなくちゃいけないんだと
そうでないと人間自由にならないんです
いわゆる意のままになってしまっちゃうんですね
耳の奴隷で 鼻の奴隷で
目の奴隷になってしまっちゃう
入るものは見ると 入るものは聞くと
入るものを味わうと そういう風になってしまうと
精進は必要 使うと耳に音が入った時に
それは聞かないで これは聞くと
いろんなものを目に入った時に
それは見ないで これは見ると自分で自分をコントロールする
例えば瞑想っていうのは本来はもうやりたくないものなんです
全く心の流れに正反対なことですから
心の心がやりたくないものの第1はもう確実に瞑想なんです
全然 これはもう競争なし
一番心嫌がるのは瞑想することなんです
ですから 精進というのはもうどうしても必要なんです
心は貪瞋痴の方がやりやすいんです
怒るのはやりやすいでしょうに
怒らないのは難しいでしょうに
欲張るのはやりやすいでしょうし
欲張らないのは難しいし
ですから 貪瞋痴の反対に不貪不瞋不痴の方をやらせようと思っちゃうと
これは魚に歩け歩けということなんですよね
で 精進しなくちゃいけない
ですから 仏教の世界では
この心想はもう徹底的に育てるということはもう必先的なんですね
育てれば育てるほどどうなるますかというと
我々は原泥必死の犬ままではないんです
そこで自由というものが生まれてくるわけです
そこで初めて見たいものは見る
聞きたいものは聞くということが生まれてくるんです
今もみんな見たいものは私は今見ているんではないか
聞きたいものは聞いているんではないかと思っているだけであって
それは勘違いであって
犬ままなんですね 見たいものを見ているのではなくて
もう美しいものばっかり見ているだけであって
それは誰でもやるんですね
心はそういうふうに願っているんだからという
すごい自然な流れなんですね
誰かに何か言われたらすぐ怒ってしまって
それ自然な流れなんですね
ですから 瞑想しない人々は羨ましいとかね
まあ聞きたいものは聞いて
見たいものは見てとかね
そういう人々は羨ましいもなく自由でもないんです
布団不尽知の世界だけ見たいものを見て
聞きたいものを聞いている世界
そうするためにはやっぱり布団不尽知の働きも必要であるし
確実に掃除もしなくちゃいけない
次の言葉はピーティ ピーティは簡単ですね
ピーティっていうのは喜びですね
疲れました ピーティは喜び
こっちティと書いてます
その漢字はまあ大丈夫です
掃除も掃除でね 喜びっていうのはある一つの心性なんですね
まあそれは文字通りに喜び
理屈ないんです そこそちらも
何か見て楽しいと 何か音を聞いて楽しいと
なんで楽しいかとわかりますか
全然もう理由はないんです
で まあ例えば音楽の場合はね
昔の音はもうすごい決まってる
いろいろ音があって それを音楽と言ってましたし
現代はそれ決まってる音じゃなくて
いろんな雑音とかね まあ変な音をいろいろまとめて
それすっごい感激しながら聴いてるし
だから古い人々から見れば何とうるさいかと思うかもしれませんだけど
若い人々にとってはもう何と美しい音かというふうに感じちゃうんですね
そこで理屈はないんです
何か舌に味が入って ああ美味しいと感じると
何も理屈そこにないんです
そこはまあしょうがない
ある音を聴いて楽しく感じるとピーティ
ある音を聴いて楽しく感じない場合は違う心想
で なんでピーティはそちらに入りますか？と
ピーティも育てられるし
例えばあまり美味しくないというものでも
どんな味をしているんですか？とかね
そういう興味で食べてみてください
どんどんその味が分かってきますよ
それでそこによって美味しく感じ始めちゃうんです
育てられます で まあこれ聞いた話なんですけどね
これ日本人に言うことだからね
ヨーロッパ人がこの自然の音は美しく感じないんだと
ヨーロッパ人が 日本人はそれをすごく音楽に感じるんだと
という研究結果が聞きましたけど
僕はあれ完全たるでたらめだと思いますけどね
で まあそれが本当であるならばね
それはあくまでも固定概念にした
もうえらい国立大学の研究なんですけどね
最初からもう徹底した固定概念で
ヨーロッパ人が音楽はもうなんとか右脳か左脳か分かりません
そちらで聴いてるんだ
日本人がこちらで聴いてるんだとかね
そんな決まったもんじゃないんだけどね
まあ僕はまあ人間みんな同じだからね
どこかへ育てるかないかと
またそれは違いますけどね
まあ僕の場合もやっぱり右耳の方がすごい敏感で
左耳は敏感じゃないんです
いわゆる音楽機械で言えば
右の耳の方がこのシャープトーンですか
それはすっごい高い ものすごくつまみをもう抜群にもうやってるんです
こちらはもうシャープも
シャープというのはこの音楽機械のシャープ
音楽のシャープとは違うんです
で 鈍く聞こえるんですね
そこで私はこの音楽を区別して聴きたい場合は
ちょっとした音楽であろうが
この楽器一つずつ別々に聴きたいとと思うと
右で聴くんです 全部まとめてボーっと聴きたい場合は左で聴く
ということは まあ自分が自分の目と耳
その別々に働き知ってるんだからね
それまだ超能力じゃないんです
言っておきますけどね
みんなにそれできると思います
そういう能力は で 目で見ていると
いつでも両目でぴったし見てるわけじゃないんです
たまに右目が働いて たまに左目が働いたりとかね
そこをまあまあちょっと気になる
ちょっと気にするとマヌスカル使うとわかるんですよ
まあそこはまあそこら辺置いといて
で 例えば虫の音はうるさいと感じることもできる
じっと虫の音を聞いて
ああ楽しいと感じることもできます
耳を鳴らして鳴らしておけばそれだけのことなんです
いわゆる音の質ではなくて
これ心の問題ということを言いたいんですね
で 私はもう何でも疑うという一番嫌な性格で生まれちゃったんだから
人の言うことを何でも疑って自分で試す
で いろんな本なんか小さい時読んでみたら
もうなんと綺麗な鳥のなんとか声とかね
言うんです そこで私はそうとことんその鳥の声を
本物の生の声を聞いてやろうと
本当に綺麗かどうとかね
例えばヨーロッパの一番声が綺麗って言ってるどんな鳥でしたっけ？キャネリアとかね
本当かなと 聞いてみると
ああそれぐらいかと 思ったりする
それぐらい綺麗と言うんですかと
面白くないと またせっかく面白いとものすごい思うと言うんだから聞いてみようかなと聞いてみたら
なるほど こういう音にみんな綺麗な音だと言うんだとかね
そういう風にもう小さい時いろいろ自分なりの探検していたんだけど
それ自分もすごく音が綺麗と思ってる鳥がいるんです
僕にとっては音が綺麗というのは
ちゃんと曲一つ歌ってくれなきゃダメなんです
どうもどこかで切っちゃうんですね
鳥っていうのは 音は なんかもう一つノート４つぐらい足らないかな
もうちょっと 4つ付けた方がワンピースになるのにと
それ合わせちゃうと音楽なんですよ
このこの鳥の音とこの鳥のところで合わせちゃうと音楽なんですけど
それだけ聞くと もうちょっとチャラないんですね
もうノート 2つミスをするとかね
まあつけた方がいいなと思って
いわゆる 1種類の鳥がいて
もうちゃんと歌うんです
それすごい長い もう小さな鳥なんで
どれぐらい空気 どこ空気がああなんでわかりませんだけど
で あれがこれは本当の歌だと
いつは綺麗な歌声で歌ってるんだと
君たちってそこでいろいろ曲変えたりしたりして
結構頑張ってるんです
あのすっごい醜い鳥なんですけどね
それ自分だけ自分だけの発見で
まあなかなかね 朝早く起きないと聞こえないんですけどね
日本にはその鳥はいませんし
ですから まあ言いたがっているのは
この音には綺麗 綺麗な音とかね
綺麗じゃない音ということではなくて
心がそれを作るんですね
目に見えるものにも綺麗か綺麗じゃないかって
そんな決まったもんじゃないんです
それはもう我々の心がそう決めるんです
ひとつ私の個人的な経験で言うならば
私はの目が猿は醜いだという風な
この何て言いますか 刷り込まれていたいたんです
あまり見る動物じゃないんだと
で 日本に来てみたら 不思議なことみんな動物園に行ったって
みんないっぱい人が止まってるのは猿のところなんですね
みんな見るは見るは見るは見るは見るは随分時間他のとこは見ないで
で いろんな話を聞いたりすると
やっぱり日本人はやっぱり猿の方がすごく好きみたいというか
まあ見て楽しむ動物として
そこで私もなんであんな醜い動物
そんなに可愛いと見ているんですか？と思って
自分もそれからじーっとじゃあ見てやろうと
で 見るんです だから気持ち理解しなきゃダメだから
自分にとってはダメではなくて
もうちょっとどうかで落ち着けないというかね
で 見て見ていると まあどんどんどんどん可愛く
可愛いとどんどんもう分かってくるんですね
猿の赤ちゃんとかね 指なんかもうしわしわしわしわで
もう本当はすごい年取ってるおじいちゃんみたいに気持ち悪いんだけど
もうよくよく見るとすごいしわだらけで可愛いなと思っちゃうんですね
すごい可愛いんだと 顔を見てもすごいおじいちゃんの顔で小さくて
やっぱり可愛いとということは
自分の心が変わったっていうことなんですね
今の私にとっても 猿を見るとすごい
可愛く感じちゃうんですね
自分の国から帰った時はもうもうあんなもの見るものじゃない
他のこんなに綺麗な動物いるのにと
です 別にそれ動物のせいじゃないんですね
結局は それは我々の心の育ち方なんですね
だからどんなものでも可愛いと見ることもできるし
可愛くないと見ることもできるし
特にもう男性のある一つの特色ありまして
この赤ちゃんからちっちゃな子供ってものすごい苦手なんですね
それは男 人間だけじゃなくて
動物もだいたい結構いるんですよ
で このすごい猛獣みたいな犬でも子犬見たら逃げちゃうと
みんなにも怒ったり追い出したりするんだけど
そこら辺ちょっと子犬が出ても逃げる
もう苦手なんですね で
まあそれもそういうことで
でもそういう赤ちゃんも抱っこもしたがらないし
怖いし 小さな子供来るともううるさい
もううるさいなとか思ったり
じゃあそういう男性の人々もどんどん見たり触ったり
面倒見たりしちゃうと
何のことなく上手に面倒見るんです
初めはすごい嫌がるかもしれませんだけど
例えば赤ちゃんを赤ちゃんの時からもう男に任せちゃえばどうか
大変か全然大変でも何でもないんです
もう 1日2日でも完璧に面倒見るようになっちゃうんです
それはもう心が変わるということなんですね
ですから このピイティの場合は
この喜びというのは心の問題で
外界の問題ではありませんと
外に文句を言うな だからいろんな美しいところを探し
探し 歩き回らなくても
何のことないところでもピイティっていうものは生まれることはできるんですね
結構お金が節約できます
で 瞑想すると心が集中したり
心の荒波が消えたりしたりして
そうすると自然にピーティが生まれる
この荒波が消えるとピーティが生まれるんですよ
ピーティが生まれるときは心落ち着いてるんですよ
音楽を聴いて楽しい場合は気持ちがいいでしょうに
落ち着いてるでしょうに
いろんな立派な絵なんか見て
ああ すごい感動するときは
本当に気持ちも良くて落ち着いているし
ですから ピーティを作るピーティが出る一つの原因は心の落ち着きなんですね
心がイライラしたり 落ち着きがない状態だったら
いわゆる上高状態だったら
もうピーティがないんです
ですから喜びピーティが生まれるのは心が落ち着いている
それで瞑想っていうのは
もうすぐ心が落ち着くようにしているものなんです
ですから 確実にピーティが生まれるんです
瞑想がうまくいっちゃうと
ですから 瞑想の道はピーティがどんどん成長していく道なんですね
結感が生まれる道なんです
それはまあ どんな瞑想でヴィパッサナーも普通の瞑想も
どんな瞑想でも心を落ち着いてあげるということが出てくるんです
そこでピーティというものが生まれてくるんです
ということで まあヴィパッサナー瞑想でもして
もうなかなかあまり面白くないというならば
それはまあ私のことじゃなくて
まあちょっと考え直した方がいいんです
論理的にはピーティが生まれるはずなんです
で 心が落ち着いてほしいということでね
落ち着いて納得して 体の現象を見ていくと
一緒にピーティ喜びが生まれてきます
で ですから 物に頼ってピーティ生まれてもらうと作ってもらう場合は大したピーティが生まれません
絵を見て喜ぶではないか
音楽を聴いて喜ぶではないか
ご飯を食べて喜ぶではないかとか
体を動かして喜ぶではないかというと
この外の物質に頼っているんですね
その物質に我々を落ち着かせてくれる力がもう決まってるんです
なぜならば もう聞こえる音は決まってるし
時間決まってるし 例えば 3時間
4時間は音楽は聞こえません
聴くことはできないんです
美術館に行って絵を見ようと思ったっても
もう 30 分歩いちゃうと
もうもう同じ いろんなこれも立派
あれも立派だと もういきなりもうもう何て言いますか
味が消えてしまっちゃうんですよ
ですから決まってるんです
例えば有名な洋画 一つだけ持ってきて
あ これすげえすっごい綺麗な絵だなと喜ぶことはできますけど
その人やら他の有名な人々の作品全部ざーっと 100点ぐらい並んでいる
もう美術館の展覧会に行っちゃったら
あの喜びが出てこないんです
麻痺しちゃうんです 音楽の場合も
この生演奏なんかもう 2時間
3時間やっちゃうでしょ
初めの 1曲目  2曲目はもう本当に喜び
それからもう麻痺状態でただ聴いてるだけ
ですから この食べ物も同じなんですね
最初はすごく喜びしますけど
どんどんあの喜びが低下しちゃうんですね
それはこの経済学でいうユーティリティという言葉がありまして
このタバコに例えてるんですよ
もう日本でそう言うかどうかわかりませんだけど
タバコ吸いたい 吸いたくて吸いたくてたまらない人がいると
もうタバコはもう今ディマンドすごいディマンドがあるんですね
そうするとその人はタバコ1本はいくらでも買えるかもしれませんと
1本吸ったところで2本目吸うと
あの喜びがもうちょっと低い
ですから  2本目にはあれほどお金は出したくないと 3
番目  4番目  6本目  10本目になっちゃうと
まあいいやと思う 買いませんと
ユーティリティが消えちゃうんですね
なぜならば喜びが消えているんだから
ですから この物質に依存して喜びを得ようと思っても
もう量が決まっている
質が決まっている そんなに大変な喜びを感じないんです
みんなもう騙されてるだけなんです
お金いっぱい儲けて いろんな遊びをして
いろんな食べ物を食べて
もういろんなことをして楽しむ楽しむと言うんだけど
ほんのわずかな喜びしか感じられないんです
麻痺しちゃうんです すごい贅沢なさってる方々っていうのは
本当にもう麻痺状態なんですね
この体から湧いてくる楽しみっていうのはないんです
いろいろもう残飯なんか食べてる人に
ちょっとしたうなぎでも弁当でもあげちゃったら
ものすごい喜びを体中感じるかもしれません
その喜びをどんな高いうなぎ食べだっても
贅沢いっぱい贅沢なさってる人は感じないと思います
ですから この物質を追っていって喜びを味わうという道があまり長い道ではなくて
そこら辺でちっちゃな水たまりで水遊びするような感じで
海に行って水遊びするような感じではないんです
海で水遊びしようと思っちゃったら
もういくらでもできる
海水もできるし 泳もできるし
船にボートに乗っていくこともできるし
猛烈なスピードのボートに乗っていくこともできるし
もう何て言いますか あれ
波上遊ぶことはサーフィンもできるし
ダイビングもできるし
豪華船に乗って世界中回る
それはそれもできるし
もうキリがないんです
海の遊びといえば そこら辺の水たまりで遊ぼうと思っちゃったら
もう決まってるんです
これぐらいですと ですから
物質の喜びっていうのは
この水たまりで水遊びしているような感じなんですね
そこで子供だったら大喜びするでしょ
それぐらい能力ないんだからなんですね
ですから 人間もこの物質だけに留まっているのは
もう能力ないということなんですね
それで満足しているんですね
お金があって 家があって
家族があって もうもうああだこうだとかね
ちゃんとした仕事があって
私はもう生きててよかった
もう大満足やというのは
まあ子供水たまりで遊んでいるようなぐらいで
もう才能能力ないということなんですね
そういうことだから このお釈迦様はそれは喜びの道ではありませんと
それをちょっとやめて
直接心を落ち着いてみてくださいと
究極的な喜びを感じるんだと
いくらでも喜びを感じるんだと
それでコーサラ王様とちょっとしたこの話し合いがありまして
で なんか誰が一番贅沢しているんですか？と
そしたら王様 やっぱりそれはコーサラ王様っていうのは一番大きな国の王で
これはコーサラ王様だと
でも ありとあらゆる五欲を楽しめるんだから
お釈迦様 私ですと 一番贅沢している
どういうことかと言ったら
でもあなたはありとあらゆる五欲で遊んで楽しんでいることは確かです
それも楽しいんだと 毎日音楽やら踊りやら
もういっぱい もういろんな遊びで
それは楽しいと で もし 1 分間でもね
ちょっと瞬間でもね 何も見ようと聞こうとしないでね
じっと落ち着くことができれば
あなたどう思いますかと王様に言うんですね
それ楽しい？と それは一番楽しいと思いますよと
それだったら このいろんな音楽を聴いて
みんなとワイワイと踊ったりして楽しむよりは
ちょっと落ち着いた瞬間で
それは最高に楽しいと思いますと
お釈迦様はこう言うんだよ
私はね 瞬間じゃなくて
1 分間も 2 分  1 時間  2 時間
何も考えないで 何も思想がなく
全部ストップして徹底した集中